What is going on guys welcome to ict for dummies episode four today
We're gonna be going over liquidity, which is essentially the foundation of ict concepts
So we hinted a little bit at this with the previous video on market structure
We showed you how the bodies and the wicks tell two very different stories and we're gonna elaborate on this today with liquidity
So the market moves in two ways it moves to seek liquidity and it also moves to
Rebalance the range and we'll talk about rebalancing the range in the next video, but for this video
We're gonna be talking about liquidity. So liquidity is essentially fuel for the next move
So the market makers the big money when they need to fill their orders
They need to grab this cash that is resting in the market to then move price and the way that they want to and where
Is this cash that is lying? You may ask
Well, it's going to be resting in swing highs and swing lows. This candle formation is a three candle pattern
So a swing high is a lower high a high and then another lower high and then a swing low is a higher low a
Low and then a higher low
I also see a lot of beginner traders getting messed up thinking that the actual color of the candle matters when we are creating
A swing high and we are creating a swing low for example here
We have two green candles and then one red candle these colors don't matter, right?
This can be a red candle
This can be a red candle like bearish bearish bullish these candles here. These can be two green candles
This can be a red candle the colors do not matter
What you should be focusing on is the lows and the highs that are created to make these swing lows and to make the swing highs
Okay
So what does buy side liquidity and sell side liquidity actually mean we have to understand first the psychology of traders?
Let's say you want to take a short position, right?
You're betting that the market is going to move down in this scenario
Where are 90% of traders putting their stop losses?
Well, you're most likely gonna put it at that recent swing high, right?
So this is referred to as buy side liquidity
If you are in a short position you put your stop loss at this high
So you have sold contracts here and then you need to buy them back to actually get out of that position
So there is a lot of cash that is resting here. So what is big money going to do to enter into the market?
Well, they're gonna take all that cash and then they're going to move towards the direction
They want it to go versus here when you have swing lows resting here
If you are in a long position, where are 90% of traders putting their stop losses?
Well, they're going to be putting it at that low at that swing low
So what's resting here is sell stops, right?
You have sell side liquidity here because if you're in a buy position you then need to sell those orders to get out and this
Is just a huge pool of liquidity and a huge pool of cash for the market makers and for big money to then step in
And take this to then move higher
So these newly initiated swing highs and lows are gonna serve as stop losses for retail traders
Which is gonna act as a magnet for price to trade back in to grab that liquidity before the real move is actually initiated
and the reason liquidity and this lesson in general is so important is because it's gonna help you understand how to
Avoid being liquidity how to avoid being stopped out unnecessarily. Alright guys think about it this way
You want to go buy some drip, but you got no money on but your homie
He's always leaving cash at his crib just laying around $100 bills on his nightstand. So what do you do?
Obviously, you can't go buy clothes if you got no money
so you hit a lick on this kid take all that cash cash grab liquidity sweep and
Then you go buy all the drip
There's cash that's resting and it needs to be taken if you want to get dripped up
Okay guys
So start getting in the habit of marking out those obvious swing highs and swing lows
Which is gonna serve as sell side liquidity and buy side liquidity doing at the charts
You can clearly see that here. We have sell side liquidity and then at the swing high we have buy side liquidity
So as you can see here, we make our new swing low
This is gonna serve as our sell side liquidity and then we deliver higher
We take out this buy side liquidity and we create our new buy side liquidity, right?
This is our new swing high then what happens we deliver lower and we create a swing low here
We generate a new level of sell side liquidity
This is gonna be our new swing low and then price delivers higher and starts delivering lower
This becomes our new buy side level. This is gonna be our buy side liquidity price delivers lower and
Creates this new swing low is our new sell side liquidity
And then we create another swing high which is gonna be our new buy side liquidity once again
So as you can see now, right? There's a sequence of buy side and sell side being generated. We have the sell side
We had this buy side
We create a new swing low sell side new swing high buy side new swing low sell side new swing high buy side
New swing low sell side new swing high buy side and then this move
Runs through all of this liquidity comes down all the way back to this first level and now this becomes our new
sell side liquidity
finally
You can see that price runs through all this liquidity and takes out all these buy side levels and this is our new
Swing low and this is our new swing high right here
So from this range guys
Just mark out the most obvious swing highs and swing lows that you see the most obvious in this scenario is going to be
This high here and then this low here. This is sell side liquidity here. This is buy side liquidity here
These liquidity levels should be sticking out like a sore thumb guys, right?
They should be easy to spot and the more you practice spotting these liquidity pools the easier it's gonna get
Also when you're starting out like Blake said focus on these major liquidity pools, right?
You don't want to just mark out every single high and low you see and then cram up your charts with unnecessary information
This is gonna end up putting you into a gnosis paralysis and you're gonna get more confused than you have to be keep your charts
Clean guys. Alright, so we're now going to be talking about liquidity sweeps and what that actually means
I'm sure you guys have heard this term used a lot by a lot of smart money concepts traders and ICT traders what this refers
To is when big money and the market makers are grabbing
Sell stops or grabbing these buy stops that we have marked out to then move the market in their direction
So we have to think about in this way 90% of retail traders fail in the market
What do 90% of retail traders trade so they either trade support and resistance
So they trade very objectively in the sense that okay, they see this move getting made, right?
We have a really big uptrend here. So they think well if we come down and retest this low
We should do the same exact move since you know, we just have that move. So this is called support
So they'll see this as a big support level and so they'll see this big support level and they'll go long here thinking that this
Same move is going to happen and will push up higher and where will they'll put their stop losses?
Well at that low so they think about trading in a really objective way and you end up seeing that these stop losses end up
Getting ran before price actually wants to make its move
Now there's also another way that retail traders often trade and this is using breakouts
So what this breakout looks like is they'll think okay if we break below this low
Then we should continue trading lower and they'll put a short position here. And where are their buy stops going to be rested?
Well at that swing high that we had right
This is our buy side liquidity level and then they will get stopped out of their position and smart money and the market makers end
Up winning in the end
So it's a really simplify that whole analysis just understand that when one person is getting out of the market
Another person is getting put into the market because not only are people looking to get long here off that support level and then getting stopped
Out what this liquidity sweep is essentially doing is also putting people in order
So they're also filling orders and getting people into short positions and generating even more liquidity at these buy side levels
And this is why I love ICT concepts so much because there's always this narrative behind every single trade that I'm taking, right?
I'm not just marking out random support levels and random resistance levels
Like there's a reasoning for every single trade that I'm taking and this is I think absolutely necessary when you're first learning to actually
Understand how the market is truly moving the thing with ICT concepts is that you'll actually
Understand why you're taking a win or why you're taking a loss every single time
You'll understand why price is going to the next target as you get better at understanding liquidity
You'll get better at determining the overall narrative of price
This is why liquidity is so essential to ICT concepts because it is how the market moves, right guys
The market moves in two ways to either seek liquidity or rebalance ranges
We'll get into the whole ranges thing in the next video
but eventually you'll see after this whole series that everything ties together and
Plays off of each other one way or another and that's why ICT is so effective because not only does it make sense technically
But it makes sense logically as well. And if you feel lost right now, don't worry
We're gonna keep showing you some more examples to help you get the understanding of it
We'll even give you some homework at the ends
You can look over shit on your own and just get better at analyzing this whole thing
But right the general consensus is that swing highs are gonna serve as buy side liquidity swing lows are gonna serve a sell side liquidity
the reason we're teaching you how to identify this liquidity is because if you can learn to identify where that liquidity lies is
Then you'll also be able to identify when it is taken and when it is the right time to enter a trade
But for now just focus on learning how to identify liquidity
Alright guys
So looking at this chart take a few minutes here pause the video and mark out your significant swing highs that you see in your
Significant swing lows. So this is going to be your major buy side levels and your major sell side levels that you're seeing right now
On this chart and we're gonna give you guys some background music while you're doing this
We go swing high swing low liquidity we take it then we go
Okay, so here we have your major buy side liquidity and then your major sell side liquidity
Look at what has been taken and then also we have sell side liquidity resting here in the form of swing low
Sell side liquidity here sell side liquidity resting here and also sell side liquidity resting here
We also then have buy side liquidity resting here
Resting here and then this buy side liquidity to the left of us has been taken so this buy side level here
here and here
And if you're wondering why it has been quote-unquote taken it's because price already traded above these levels meaning
Therefore that liquidity has been taken and these three buy side levels that haven't been taken is going to be the liquidity that is still
Valid and where stop losses are going to be placed
so once again here you have your two major liquidity levels your buy side up here and your sell side right here and then you have
The sell side liquidity right here and this buy side liquidity right here. This has already been taken
So watch as I play out price now and it targets this buy side liquidity up here
Which is going to be holding a bunch of buy stops
Right for anyone who's in a short anyone who's in a short is stopped out right here because this is where all the stop losses
Are resting for shorts and then we go ahead and trade towards that sell side liquidity
Bang and after all of these sell stops are ran and these retail traders are taken out of the market and once the market
Makers have grabbed all of that cash and grabbed all that liquidity
They then move price towards the direction that they want it to and they target this buy side liquidity here
And also these swing highs that are put into the market here
So guys as we wrap up this video on liquidity
I decided to show you a four-part illustration which summarizes exactly what we had taught you
So if you look all the way on the left here
The first thing that happens is a swing high is created that swing high becomes a buy side liquidity, right?
If people are going to be shorting their market
Where are the buy stops going to be sitting at the swing high at this buy side liquidity?
Remember those are interchangeable words buy side liquidity swing high then what happens?
This buy side liquidity is traded away from people are shorting and their buy stops are resting right here
Why is it called buy stops because they're shorting the market and so if they get stopped out in the case where you're trading futures
Your contracts are being bought back then third step in the process of buy side liquidity being traded away from
sell side liquidity is created and
After the sell side liquidity is created price goes ahead and takes out the buy side liquidity
So now we are stopping out all the people who were shorting the market where buy stops are resting at this swing high and
Finally price trades now to the next liquidity, which is gonna be you know
That's sell side liquidity we had created or any other liquidity that is resting further down in the market
So break it down into four parts guys first identify worthy swing highs and swing lows are created
Once you find that notice how price will typically trade away from this level which ends up resulting in a manipulation
Move for 90% of retail traders then that level is traded back into
Those retail traders are stopped out and then the real move is initiated
The whole reason that ICT concepts is so important and that liquidity is so important is because it one serves as a foundation
But two is gonna help you avoid being liquidity, right?
You need to understand liquidity to avoid ending up as liquidity that being said this practically concludes our
ICT for dummies episode 4 liquidity. We teach you how to make money
And now for your homework after that lovely song on liquidity
We're gonna give you two assignments first being identify simply buy side and sell side liquidity levels on the chart
And then also identify liquidity sweeps
So first find out where these swing highs and swing lows are being created and then when price goes ahead and takes them and try
To start noticing how price reacts off of these liquidity levels. We're gonna get way more into liquidity with more videos
It's actually gonna be three parts of liquidity. So this is the quiddity part one
You're gonna have liquidity part two and the quiddity part three because there is a lot to talk about but for now
Let's keep it simple. This is your homework fellas. That being said, that's it
But it's time for you